but check out this amazing sunrise isn't
that gorgeous so we just closed the iris
of the camera down just a little bit
just because it was so bright but
man is it beautiful clear as a bell out
there so speaking of bells and school
bells kiddos it is chilly this morning
we have an average of some upper 30's
around the valley with clear skies and
light winds overnight so warm coats this
morning and make sure you've got lots of
water in the backpack because of these
dry north breezes today it's going to be
very dry air it's already really dry out
there should get into some low 60s
thanks with the wind that will be
stirring around through the day
look at this seven hills is 31. nellis
is 33. aleonte 37 summerlin at 34 in
mountains edge at 33 right now so wow it
is cold so our headlines breezy to gusty
north winds today and again next week as
we roll into february more clouds around
at times through the weekend
and then sunny but chilly 50s to start
off february next week so keep the nice
warm coats around you're going to need
them snow through the mid-south this
morning the ohio valley and a nor'easter
that's getting ready to roll right into
the east coast through the weekend and
man that's going to combine with the
cold air coming from the west and
moisture off the atlantic they're
looking at maybe one to two feet of snow
in some areas of new england this
weekend high pressure expanding from
all the way from southern canada through
the great basin in the desert and as
that high pressure strengthens the winds
increase wind advisories for the
colorado river valley out to lake mead
today 11 a.m to 7 p.m look for those
winds that could get up to 45 miles an
hour in those areas 63 for the valley as
i said northeast winds about 25 miles an
hour for the valley no wind advisories
but still going to be bumpy you might
want to turn your sprinklers off today
save some water sunny skies back
tomorrow or again tomorrow i should say
temps down a little bit clouds around
saturday and at times through the
weekend nice mid 60's to finish january
and then boy we start off february windy
again on tuesday and much cooler mid 50s
as we get through groundhog day on
wednesday